hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer klitzekleinen mod vorstellung und
zwar werde ich ziemlich ziemlich oft von
leuten gefragt was denn dieses minecraft
forge 6.0 punkt 1.341 unten eigentlich
bedeutet beziehungsweise zehn muscheln
geladen
10 mode sind aktiv und so weiter und
zwar bedeutet das ganz einfach dass ich
den fortschritt installiert hat und das
ist der mord um den es heute gehen wird
und zwar bitte die am ende weil die mod
vorstellung ist schon ziemlich kurzes
noch ein tutorial sehen wir das
überhaupt installiert beziehen werde ich
euch ganz kurz zeigen wie man das so
ungefähr macht und ja ich möchte euch
ganz gut sagen was der mut macht und
zwar könnt ihr damit leicht zu
installieren ganz einfach also wenn ihr
fortschritt wenn ihr den fortschritt
installiert habt habt ihr hier halt noch
so ein kleines minütchen das heißt mods
und dort sind alle mods aufgelistet die
ihr installiert habt das heißt an
tornados habe ich drin extended renderer
also dass er das noch besser rändern
kann sage ich mal nen tornados sind
einfach dass das ein paar blätter
rumfliegen bei traffic kraft blog
brauche ich auf die kräfte ist robbie
kraft in sich drin lassen alle sachen
für trittkraft mappus ist zum beispiel
dass wenn ich die items wechsel des das
holz kommen inventory tricks habe ich
einfach mal eingepackt noch nie getestet
das ist einfach wenn ich auf eine taste
drücke das dann sich an das inventar
ordnet minecraft fort
das ist das worüber das rasante
fortschritt braucht man auch order pack
warum nicht den hat weiß nicht ob die
fein ist ganz einfach dass man weiter
sehen kann suchen usw und forschens
macht es euch quasi leichter mode zu
installieren und wie das genau
funktioniert das zeige ich euch jetzt
mal eben so und hier befinden wir uns
nun auf meinem desktop und zwar habe ich
hier schon mal den fortschritt ordner
aufgerufen den ihr euch downloaden könnt
den link findet ihr unten eben der
beschreibung da unten irgendwo und zwar
wird in eurem downloads vorderland so
weitergeht wird an minecraft client
minecraft forge kleinen 1.6 kann man das
mittlerweile schon eine neuere version
draussen ist jedenfalls intakt ideen mit
ich habe zum beispiel sap kann ich nur
empfehlen
dann habt ihr hier ganz ganz viele klar
dass dateien kopiert ihr einfach alle
und dann gibt die hier unten bei
programme und dateien prozent update ein
klickt einfach unter dann kommt ihr hier
in sonnenfenster dort klickt ihr auf
punkt minecraft dort auf bin und dann
habt ihr hier moment so dann habt ihr
hier einen minecraft ordner das ist eine
jahr feier der macht einfach rechtsklick
die bei mir ist das service ab und dann
könnt ihr das ganz einfach öffnen so
dann haben wir das hier das ist die
minecraft jahr all die sachen ausgepackt
also die ganzen dateien drin ohne die
wird das spiel nicht laufen also nur
deswegen läuft das spiel und diese
ganzen sachen zieht ihr einfach beim
hierüber ich hab das schon gemacht
deswegen lasse das jetzt einfach und ihr
habt ihr nachher noch ein meter in
ordner da macht einfach rechtsklick
drauf löschen und dann die leitet er den
also den meter in flotten löschen
danach startet ihr eure minecraft und
dann sollte unten links eigentlich
stehen minecraft forge blabla und so
weiter und jedenfalls generiert sich
dabei dieser ordner also ihr könnt euch
noch daran erinnern als enorm waren
schon die mannschaft dann geht man rein
ist hier der mods ordner und hier könnt
ihr nun einfach mit reinziehen die frage
ich mal unterstützen das ist zum
beispiel top craft assad muss das ist
der audi modi race minimap und immer
wenn ihr euch dann zum beispiel top
craft runterladen kriegt halt einfach
nur subtil und die zieht dann einfach
nur da rein das heißt nichts mit öffnen
und in den minecraft lassen von diesem
fall da rein ziehen also forsch ist
quasi der einfachere model oder in
unserer heutigen zeit so das war's dann
auch schon wieder von einem tutorial
hier zu einem neuen motto ich hoffe ich
konnte euch ein bisschen näher bringen
weil es ein wenig kürzer und ein
bisschen anders aber es wird mal wieder
verlangt und vor allem wurde dieser mod
auch verlangt wenn ihr neue mit wenn ihr
neue mods westig eventuell mal
vorstellen soll könnt ihr mir die
vielleicht wenn ihr wollt in die
kommentare schreiben und dann würde ich
sagen ich würde mich über eine bewertung
freuen und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
videothek